[Music]
hello
and welcome everyone as folks continue
to join us
my name is will torres i'm one of the
admission officers at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to diversity and leadership
connect with community
this is one of our very special panels
that features some of our global
interests and um social clubs
so tonight um here in palo alto maybe
daytime wherever you might be tuning in
from um we are
featuring the greater china business
club and gsb india club
so really excited to have our panelists
here with us so with that
we can start with um student
introductions if we could do name
what you were doing before the gsb and
what do you hope to do after so maybe
david if we could start with you please
sure thanks will hey everyone thanks for
joining us
from all these very diverse places my
name is david
i'm from china and singapore so right
before this i took a slightly
um i guess unconventional path so i was
a media entrepreneur
and then i was a consultant but i was
focusing very much on startups during my
consulting days
and then i worked at a fintech startup
focusing on microfinance
and after the gsb i'm looking at either
going to vc or doing my own startup
nice thank you
yeah hi i'm chancha
one second just one second i have some
uh
special friend johnny
yeah sorry about that we had some hiccup
in her joining from her
computer so um
sure um i'm chantal i'm from uh jaipur
rajasthan in india
um before gsp i was working with
startups like ola cabs and zlingo
and product and data roles and poor csb
uh so this summer i work on my
startup idea and if all goes well i'll
likely be working on that for csv
and here's my roommate hi
um i'm also uh from india before gsp i
worked in investment banking and then
impact investing
um and over the summer i worked um i did
a split summary i worked in consulting
and then i worked with a startup back in
india
um and i'm looking to go back to the
impact space either in the startup or
in an impacted investing role nice
and then allocate hey everyone
thanks so much for joining thanks will
uh i'm a lockheed terry is home for me
in india before gsp i was an
entrepreneur in india in the digital
healthcare space
post tsp want to keep continue being an
entrepreneur and hope to start something
soon nice all right so just to get us
started
um if we can learn a little bit more
about your organizations
um knowing that you know david
still early for you but really excited
to hear how you came to join um greater
china business club
for those of you in the audience if you
have questions for our panelists
throughout
please feel free to go ahead and put
them in the q a we're definitely going
to be tapping into that later on
and even throughout the session as they
arise so david can you please start off
and tell us a little bit about
greater china business club sounds good
hey everyone
so uh i've only been at the gsb for two
months but my
connection with gsbn also with the
greater china business club started
several months ago
so right after i got in like i started
getting a lot of calls from alums from
students
and people are just extremely um
sociable
and just like super excited to meet me
and also meet some of my classmates
so the greater china business club
reached out very early on
uh to try to like you know bring you
into like different whatsapp wechat
groups
uh connect you to like people that you
know work in similar places or
um wanna like they have more experience
in places that
uh you wanna get exposure to so i just
felt pretty intimate
and felt very close this community like
even before i got to the gsb campus
uh and overall i think it's a part
professional part
social club so on the social side we
we do like events we invite speakers
um i like there's just like so many
incredible events i did an event
yesterday
with the president of mastercard asia um
i think people love food as well so we
try to do food events as much as
possible
i think maybe with cove it's a bit
harder but
my sense is that on in a useful year
there's a lot of food events
and on the professional side i think
there's quite a lot of
things going on with alarms so gsb alums
are super tight you know they really
enjoy the gsb experience then they take
any opportunity to come back
and reconnect with um current students
and all that so
uh we do that quite a bit and also we we
we do like more professional talks
um and some recruiting events as well
so that's my that's my very brief
experience
that sounds like a lot for just a few
weeks on campus
so that's pretty exciting for um
um can you please tell us a little bit
about a gsb
india club and there is a question
already about
maybe what's the best thing for you
knowing that it could be very different
for different people
so go ahead tell us about the club and
what's what's your favorite thing about
it
um i can kick us off so i'll start with
the club and let everybody to give their
take on their favorite thing
the purpose is we want to connect
everybody at gsb indians people of
indian origin
and anybody with an interest in india um
with things that are going on
um back in india and so we look at it in
three different ways
uh social cultural and professional
stuff in terms of social i think we
really
try to build a community when i came in
it was um
it was already like a biggest group of
mba tours who
um who were already from india or were
just interested and it was just
we had small group dinners we celebrated
festivals with them and so it was just
very warm and it made it very easy to
settle in
um so we hope to continue that with like
events for community members
um small group dinners and things uh the
next one is cultural
um so diwali is coming up i think will's
pointed it out a couple of times
we're doing uh even in kobe we're able
to do a lot of food takeout we have a
surprise gift for people we're doing
something on zoom
we do this for holi we do things in yoga
dance
sessions that everybody can join so just
a lot of cultural engagement
um and finally on the professional front
um we're at
we have a lot of sgds that prefer she
did a small group than us sorry for
anybody who didn't know that
um but we do dinners with professors who
are who work
on the region um alums i think david
mentioned it there's a very active album
community
uh indian diaspora as well as people
back in india um
so we have them um come over off and
then we also have a lot of speaker
series that happen
um and this year we're also partnering
with a couple of other organizations
at stanford i'll stop there and electron
children are located
yeah it's difficult to pick one thing
that's uh
that's favorite but so far i think i've
enjoyed our diwali celebrations
uh in terms of cultural stuff and and
just the community i think
this community was the first one to make
me feel at
home even before i got here like there
was this whatsapp group where i could
ask questions like
hey so where do i buy bed sheets from
you know because i can't carry them with
me and i want i needed to have them on
day one
so just the community is so beautiful
and um
yeah and yeah i'm okay i'll let you
chime in on the professional stuff but i
otherwise i would just say i like
everything about this
yeah i think just to like add uh i i
think i relate a lot with what mona and
gentle said but just to add if i had to
kind of give
one more a sentence for what the india
club is like
the india club and the indian community
at general at gsp
uh feels like family rather than a club
or a community
so it's like a group of us together who
like
like family like we can go to each
other's room get like chai whenever we
want like celebrate whatever we do
and the interesting thing about just
it's not only the india club per se like
even before we came to stanford like
alums in india called us over to their
houses and just like
treated us as as if we were part of some
like family and not rather like a
community or a network like
not a very professional very very um
i would say like less professional setup
so i think that's the best thing about
uh about about the india club it's like
a family away from home
and then david in your first few months
here on campus
what are any favorite moments for you
with uh greater china
um there has been quite a few uh
good moments i i think a lot of it is
what um a little cake just said a lot of
it's like just in the daily stuff right
having this community
that's always there it's like just today
i needed to like get something for like
contact lens
and i just like ping the group and i
don't i don't ever feel like i'm ever
gonna be judged and it's just like
community
where people like three people replied
me within half an hour saying like you
know hey i have it
you know just come to my room and get it
and i think that's sort of like
um oh and and even like an hour ago i
was
trying to get some advice on taking
classes and like you just
you know write a question and people
like hey do you want to call five
minutes from now
so i i think maybe it's less about some
particular experiences but more around
that
sort of like ongoing community and just
sense of belonging
that i think most of us have mentioned
in
two different degrees here
robert are you there can you hear us
all right we have another panelist who
will be joining us shortly but
yes well oh awesome they are hey robert
can you go
ahead and please i'm so sorry i had to
hello hello
hi
are you in a moving vehicle at the
moment
are you in a flight my connection is not
very stable
well either way thank you so much for
going out of your way to join us tonight
knowing that
you know um situations are all over the
world like literally
um so can you please introduce yourself
what you were doing before the gsp and
what you hope to do
after
sure uh because i'm on a train so
uh i will just uh shut down my videos so
that the connection is
a bit better i'm so sorry about this so
hi everyone
i'm currently nba2 at gsb uh before gsp
i worked for uh facebook china so i was
managing the ads business uh in mainland
china
but most of them are in beijing uh i was
based out of hong kong
and post gsb uh i'm actually
i'm actually looking for opportunities
to start my own companies
uh if that doesn't work out i will
probably join nbc
in china nice it actually sounds like
there's a lot of the spirit of
entrepreneurship
coming out in multiple ways here and
that's a question that's coming up a lot
in our q and a box
so i figured if we can just go ahead and
go there um
as you think about for mba 2s
some of the things that are helping you
explore entrepreneurship
and then for david or nba1 what are some
of the things you're looking forward to
as you're considering your different
career options um
can you talk about some of the resources
that uh the gsb has to help
entrepreneurs
i can start unless stencil wants to
yeah so i think uh the resources in
general which gsp has are
multitudes so one is obviously the
academics part of it
the other is other is like classmates
and like
who and professors etc who we can get to
know
and the third is really like the
community outside of gsp which includes
alums or people access which we have
and then there are like these other
things like the um
i think chanchal since he was in a
program can talk about this much better
than me but in general about
uh uh the stanford venture studio and
things on campus etc so if i start with
academics and the kind of courses which
we have um
so they're divided into two like we have
so many courses which just teach
about like entrepreneurship cases looks
at a lot of
a lot of like ex-entrepreneurs how they
went through the journey
uh right now i mean one called formation
of new ventures which talks about
different types of uh different types of
entrepreneurs different kinds of
structures which is super interesting to
know as an
uh entrepreneur and there are a bunch of
other ones there's this entrepreneurship
and venture capital this
angel in venture financing i mean almost
anything related to entrepreneurship you
will find a course
uh focused towards that the second type
of courses
which are very interesting are
experiential courses and here what we
have are
courses like startup garage which is
like a typical gsb
uh course uh in which a bunch of us are
right now wherein
you actually work on your idea uh every
week
just go start with the concept and by
the end of the course kind of have
a prototype in place uh so it's super
experiential
very like um gs you work very closely
with gsb alums who
have built businesses and know about
stuff so that's that's
primarily around uh the academics part
i think a great part of building
anything or
or entrepreneurship in general happens
with um
a lot of classmates which you have so
for example i was trying to figure out
things in medical devices and trying to
work something there all i did was
post on my on the slack channel in the
health care slide channel
uh uh of our class and i just got
connected to five people who worked in
uh medical devices who knew the industry
so well and were
able to quickly give me an overview of
what this thing is
and that's true with professors like
professors by far gsb are like
so well connected no everyone it's just
phenomenal
and then i i think to talk more about
like venture studio and other like more
uh like outside of class and social kind
of thing i think
chanchal is a much better person since
she did the both
summer internship and i would pass it on
to her
um so over the summer there's this new
program that got
created uh last summer and we are the
first batch to go through
uh which is called both our chen summer
entrepreneurship
where uh where we had one alarm sponsor
24
teams of mba twos or uh
to work on their startup idea um
it was super unstructured in the sense
that we had all the freedom to do what
we wanted to do
uh but structured enough that every
three weeks we had to give a
presentation to
to keep us accountable and make sure we
were doing this and at the
end of it we got to present our ideas to
bunch of venture capitalists where
and we got a great feedback some some of
us
you know but offered for further
conversations if you interest
if you were interested in raising um
raising any funds so i think that was
super helpful
in fact also that program also provides
you a mentor
who is in the industry that you're
working in and it's just
amazing to see someone who is currently
building a hot
startup in the in their space we talk to
you every two weeks
give you feedback on anything and
everything connect you with relevant
people in the industry again
uh and i i think it's as good as it gets
anywhere
in terms of entrepreneurship resources
yeah
uh for the internship were there any
like
aha moments that you've had over the
course of it
uh yeah so we had a first check-in with
ruloff boza and for context he's like
the md of sequoia
uh managing partner of sequoia us
and i had in my mind that you know
there's one thing that i wanted to try
out and i was like maybe we can add
blockchain
in the problem that we're trying to
solve and
and so how do we find out whether that's
going to work out or not and the night
before
we were like sure let's put it in the
presentation let's see how he reacts
and based on that it'll be a good
estimate and so we just did that and he
quickly gave us a bunch of feedback on
you know i think these are the things
that are working well
and it was just so amazing otherwise for
us to get the same things done
it would have taken us a long time you
know to talk to a lot of people but he
uh he has clearly seen a lot of startups
in this space so
uh that was that was uh
that was very efficient in the very
least nice
then david and robert how are you or how
do you want to explore
your entrepreneurial interests
you can't go first oh okay sure um yeah
i think for me i'll put it broadly under
two categories one would be like the
very structured and formal type
and one is really like the more organic
informal spontaneous type
so i think the more structure one i
think allocate um
muneo has mentioned it like there are a
lot of classes there's
some of the more famous ones are like
lean launchpad startup garage
um very structured stuff where you take
a class
and you get a credit for starting a
company so you have like people who
mentor you and all that
um there's also like a lot of talks so
you want to know more about
food tag you're going to know more about
ad tech fintech
that's just like a lot of speakers and
events um so i think that those are the
more structured stuff i think
to me for me i really enjoy the more
unstructured stuff
um so one is just like talking to
classmates
because i think even within the gsb
within the same class as you
and if you're taking like you know the
class above or below you
and if you go beyond the gsb to other
parts of stanford like there's always
someone around on campus who knows
some geography super well or some
industry super well or some
type of problem super well so you can
always find someone
um that that you can reach out to um
and a lot of like cool initiatives like
team information and all that
so we can just put your name and you can
either find people to talk to and form
teams wait for people to reach out to
you
so i i put my name there and some people
have reached out
um and then the last thing i would say
is that uh to the point of like
the more unstructured stuff like just
being in the heart of silicon valley
like this is probably the best place you
can be if you want to do something busy
you want to work with startup
like they're all just right next to you
so for me one of the areas i want to
explore is
education and future of work so i just
like
playing one of the vc's here called our
ventures
they're probably the biggest vc in the
education space
and like someone there who's a gsb alum
will just like talk to you and
sort of create a program around your
interest
and that's to me just like pretty
incredible
yeah so that's my that's my experience
the future of work
sounds like it must be so fascinating
right now like
it's on top of everybody's minds that's
amazing
i know i think so i think with zoom and
just
i think we're all gonna work in a very
different way so
yeah that's a topic i'm quite excited
about
and it sounds like a lot all of you are
kind of at the forefront of that with
like some of the things you're exploring
and like the advice and
guidance that you're getting i'm so
excited for you and everything that's
going to come down your path
um robert was there anything you wanted
to add there
yeah sure so actually i think my
approach is
a little bit different because i know i
will come back to china actually i'm in
china right now because of the kobe
um so i think gsp is a great platform
for me to start with but it's not the
only resource you end up with
right so i i got connected to a lot of
very short resources because of gsp
for example i work with a i'm working
with a top tier vc in china
the founding partner was a gsp alum and
actually he was based in palo alto
so you know you know two months into our
gsp
experience it took us awkward dinner
and you know and get to know us things
like that
after that because of this resource
i was connected to many other people uh
and
i think that's the iteration uh
you know i i repeat it for many times
you know
you get to know some people and through
them you can just kill some other people
and it's it's going to be a widespread
network out there
so i think gsp really gives you this
kind of kind of buy
that because of silicon valley and
stanford a lot of people
are thinking about this right but your
idea
your path is unique so you really need
to find your
the resources you need and
just be a step in this starting point to
get you there
but in the end you you'll realize many
people you get to know
are not related to stanford at all but
because of stamper
you really have this platform to get get
you know reintroduce too many people
that's my uh presence nice
there's a couple questions here on like
the international experience
and then coming down to like how like
your cultural background
has impacted life on campus so maybe if
we can zoom down
that way um can you talk a little bit
about your experience like as an
international student what are some of
the things you're considering
um including like how are you
approaching um
like post gsb life thinking about
work visas where in the world do you
want to end up what resources are you
using to help you approach that
so pretty open-ended
i couldn't take the first stab at it oh
wait gentlemen
were you going to add something okay so
will can you just say the question one
more time so it's like
how do yeah can you have the experience
for
uh as an international student coming to
the gsb how
what was that like and then as you're
thinking about you know post gsb
um how are you approaching that knowing
that there's things like visas
and oh potentially opt what are some of
the resources that you're that are
helping you kind of figure out what
comes next
got it so i think like as a uh as an
international student it the first few
weeks i think for
all students not only international but
even for people who are here the first
few weeks tend to be a little
overwhelming just because you're
suddenly meeting so many students and
uh you're just like you want to meet
everyone but there's so many students
you're trying to understand how
academics is and everything but it just
takes some time and then you get used to
it
i think for me personally having like a
lot of people who i already knew from
india with me was really helpful early
on just
uh talking to them etc i think with
respect to our question about like
how do you find stuff i think a lot is
just reflection i think gsp is a great
place where
it really forces you to think about the
why in life for a lot of questions uh
both like uh professional
non-professional etc and i think that's
just having more time and
constantly questioning the why is a
great way of just
understanding your motivations etc
better in terms of more like tactical
where you want to be etc and visa things
uh
in fact me and chanchal were this week
with
cmc session which was specifically for
uh
if you want to be an entrepreneur after
uh after gsp as an international student
what are the visa options here and
in general i think there's the opt which
guarantees you
i don't know if it guarantees you but
you can work for a year um
uh on that and then extend it for two
two more years since the mba at stanford
is now a stem degree too
uh so this there's that and then you can
always apply for an h1b there's the over
an extraordinary visa and other
opportunities to kind of work even as an
entrepreneur here
nice i know that's that's a question a
lot of folks have because
striking out on your own sometimes it's
you don't know what all of the support
systems are so
i love that you're checking in with the
career management center
um there's some pretty awesome people um
david so alec mentioned
coming to campus feels overwhelming as
one of our mba ones can you confirm that
how how much of truth is there behind
that
no i think it's like 200 true um
yeah definitely um feels very
overwhelming if once you get here i
would say overall it's
good overwhelming uh in all fairness
like
there's just like so many interesting
classmates you want to meet
there's like so many interesting events
you want to go
uh but one thing i do feel um as part of
that is
you just have to and also to a
a little kick's point it's like i think
you have to reflect on
who you are and what truly matters to
you because everything looks
sexy and interesting and fun and shiny
but uh even for me i'm like i said nba
one i'm starting to think about like
hey what do i want to do professionally
like who do i want to spend more of my
time on
with and all that and that helps you to
like sort of prioritize
i wish i had so much wisdom as david in
the first few months at gsp
no i think i'm just uh i think for us
it's just yeah pretty overwhelming
uh and mid terms are like oh my god time
flies by so quickly
yeah it's more survival
you're going to be a gsb old-timer
before soon so
um you'll you'll figure out the ropes
chancho
can you talk a little bit about how
like your cultural background as an uh
international student
or all of the different dimensions of
who you are kind of influence the way
that you might move through the gsb
yeah for sure so um i
moved to the us and i first i came to
the us to
start business school and i had never
been here and i had hardly traveled
um anywhere else outside of india before
so uh coming here first few weeks were
especially all the more overwhelming for
me and i found it
difficult to understand ref pop culture
references like
i don't watch uh american sports i don't
watch
um a lot of english movies i haven't i
listen to only bollywood music so
there was there were little things that
i could talk
talk to people about early on when you
don't know folks enough and you know a
lot of conversations are centered around
these uh
um these things and um yeah i mean it
was it was hard
and you know with time it um
two things happen a you start to
understand things a little bit now i
know what the difference between
football and soccer
and things like these
and also with time as you start to
understand your um you know get to know
people better you find out what things
that you can talk to each other about
what are uh what are the
other common interests that you have
which don't come up in the first attempt
and um if i find it one of
the things that i really like at gsp is
its diversity and inclusion initiatives
um and if i can talk a little bit about
that uh
so we have um
how do i yeah how do i how do i explain
this so
um there is this uh this is a
mandatory curriculum for first year
students where
you put in groups of age seven to eight
to nine and
uh these are facilitated by second year
students and you talk about things
related to
like diversity and inclusion uh a lot of
things i did not
know i learned that was also a place
where i could talk about how i was
feeling
uh and i think that group made me feel
also like i had felt at home with indian
community i
felt at home with few friends that i was
making but at that place i could
talk about you know where i was
not feeling uh i fit in and i think that
helped uh help others understand how
people from different backgrounds are
thinking about and i also became more
conscious
uh about other folks in the group who
could be feeling similarly you know so
that was a good learning experience for
everybody all everyone so we started
incorporating what we were learning in
those sessions
going forward with our classmates and i
um
i think that just helped everybody feel
better feel at home
better just um
and one i think chancha is one of the
leaders of the board
that she was talking about so she's
giving back um
just um outside of this there's a lot of
structured places as chancellor
mentioned like pods which
help you you know get up that learning
curve pretty soon but
over time i think it can also be sort of
an advantage because everybody comes to
gsb
or to business school in general like
you know they they
uh looking for diversity we all want to
learn from different experiences
and so for instance with diwali like we
have 100 people joining us there's like
five people from india right so uh
there's like a lot of celebration that
we can share with people um i'm a part
of the china club and that's not
something
i knew so much about but um you know
there's events that i can join in
chanchal has people over for chai
which is uh something different for them
to explain
so um once you know you come up that
learning curve there's a lot
of ourselves that we're able to share
with the community
um and that makes it very special to me
um well no you just mentioned um being
part of
china club i know for many of us like
you'll have like this hub of like maybe
like some of the clubs that you find
like first and that's your first family
but a lot of you are part of
many clubs so i guess this is a two-fold
question
so one what are some of the other clubs
that you're a part of and like you know
what are some of the things that you're
talking about there
um and two how do you balance your time
between academics professional
as well as like the social and all the
involvement in the clubs any tips
at all for our attendees or for each
other
or for me
i let another
which was that join as many clubs as you
can you get a lot of free food
for lunch that's what my strategy is
first year
i i i guess david you wouldn't have
experienced this but i'm sure robert
jungle and mono have experienced this
which is
first year almost every day there was
like a club event during lunch time
and you just get free food there and an
awesome speaker and it was a great way
to know about it
on a serious note like answering your
questions on what other clubs are there
there are a bunch of different clubs
right from like uh identity clubs like
the india club and the china club then
they're like
professional clubs like the tech club
venture capital club entrepreneur club
like a bunch of different clubs
um and then i think industry-focused
ones like healthcare
and a few and then there are these like
golf wine clubs and
i mean almost all of them are pretty
like according to what your interest
is um apart from the india club i spent
a lot of time around the tech club
the entrepreneur club the venture
capital club but what i basically had as
a strategy was
uh very close to like the free food and
the lunchtime strategy so you have
every day 12 to 1 you have time and i
just used to go in for an event for any
club
just sit there in the bbl which is
basically a brown bag lunch wherein a
speaker comes in during lunch time and
you
go go there go in there and just listen
to a random thing so i remember going
for random topics right blockchain
quantum computing like food and
agriculture club events around how
plant-based
meat is coming up just random things and
that was just like a very interesting
way to discover new things which i had
absolutely no
idea about so that's how i balanced like
knowing new or exploring different
things
and do your answer will about balancing
social academics
and and maybe a startup
uh i i don't know who has that answer i
haven't met a single person who can
answer how to balance uh
these three things together that's fair
and i'm cracking up because
there's a comment or a question uh in
the q a box about besides
cultural and food connections but it
sounds like
the food is more like a vehicle where
connections happen
over so it's as much about the relation
that that's formed around that
um and for me food is love so this
it's kind of hilarious to hear it keep
coming up as a theme throughout the week
yeah just one more thing and i promise
not to take up more time uh
i think for especially with respect to
food i think my highlight in the first
year was this concept called
small group dinners at gsp which
basically means that
um every week uh
students host a dinner which could you
can either cook you can order in
for which the student association kind
of gives us money like every
everyone has like a 10 or 15 a person
budget so basically the school is paying
you for
uh having food with a group of small
group of nine or ten people and i
thought like
that dinner with 10 people when
somebody's cooking
food from their home like home or
they're just ordering in or going to a
restaurant was
where i met so many people and had so
many wonderful conversation
so that was at least one of the top
highlights for me during my first
um year just like to add that i haven't
been here for that long but i've
loved the small group of dinner uh it's
one of the highlights i've had i went
for
sushi making one like last week and it
was so bomb
just want a second
chancha i know you do some really
awesome work
with um our women in management club can
you talk a little bit about some of the
intersections there
yeah i think women in management club
has been
one of the clubs that i have been very
active in and
so in this club that club has a lot
a just to quickly first clarify it's not
only for women
there are a lot of males who are part of
that club as well but
a lot of the conversations are around
how do we um
close the equity gap for women in
business
how do we make sure we have more women
in business and
you know how do we share responsive
family responsibilities how do we
figure out maternity um and a lot of
these conversations cannot be done just
with women in the room so we do have a
lot of participants from
maine uh our other main classmates as
well
um one thing that i love the most about
them is they win
circles which is where your par you are
paired with
again seven to eight of your classmates
and have a facilitator and you
you meet a 172 weeks
over food again and talk about things
that are either top of mind for someone
uh you know or you you have a lot of
facilitated conversations around
how how do you nurture certain
relationships how are you thinking about
family planning depending upon what the
group decides
i think that group has uh because we see
each other so often and
you know that group usually continues
for both the years and not just for one
year
um those are come become one of my
closest friends here at the gsb
nice and then robert um
what about you any other organizations
that have been
uh like influential or really special
during your time at the gsb
okay he may be in a a low reception spot
on his train shooting across asia so
whenever he can
join us um we'll be happy there
so um question here this kind of covers
a few different themes
but given the shift well let's start
pre-covet for our mba twos um
have you participated in any um like
global experiences
and have any of them um gone to uh like
the greater asia region
should i essentially do you want to
since both of us did exactly the same
sorry i was answering a question on the
chat um
how long do you want to take that up
first yeah sure so uh
so do you think so uh we uh chancellor
and me were on the
so there's this concept called global
study trips so
if we take a step back um
every student or gsp has to fulfill
what's called a global experience
requirement
which you can do in multiple ways uh you
can do it either by
uh doing a global study trip you could
do it either by
doing what we call a gmix which is
basically an internship with an
international organization but the the
intent of that is that you
kind of go out there and experience a
new culture so for me
after my first quarter me and i i think
chanchal and i both went to a global
study trip in china wherein we went to
shenzhen
and beaching and met incredible people
there founders of companies venture
capital funds people working
in in some government places and i think
that was really nice for me to know
about how
china is and what uh what's happening
there uh the topic was also pretty
interesting around the intersection of
artificial artificial intelligence
and how that's impacting jobs uh in
china
um and it was pretty good i made so many
friends there was just 30 of us
there uh and secondly like uh both
all of us like mona and chelmy were
doing the same
organizing the same global study trip to
take people back to india so we usually
have two global study trips in india
every year
uh wherein we take other classmates
especially mba ones uh
there uh so that's that's how things
happen pre-covered
yes a lot of this not just pre-covered a
lot of this is on
virtually it's not it's not the same at
all but
um i'm right now doing an exchange
program with china
and all the study trips are happening
virtually
to the extent that's possible yeah so
with that shift to virtual like how
like what kinds of things are you able
to do in that virtual environment to get
the um
to get some of that global perspective
come on um i can start with the step
piece i think
um this step is an exchange program with
shringa for instance and i'll talk about
the regular classroom
um stuff after um i thought what was
would be most valuable for me it's a
relationship like getting to meet
uh my peers from singapore and building
relationships with them understanding
what their life is like
and so that's still happening because um
i have a small group we meet every week
on zoom
um and so i've made two new friends
people have i have on my
chat i can talk to um who are arranging
like sessions for us even virtually with
people that i want to meet specifically
so it can be very personalized when you
go travel as a group it's hard to like
uh for me to have a conversation with
someone and my channel have a
conversation with someone else but
that's possible in this
world um so it's of course i mean it's
not ideal
but there are advantages of being
virtual um
or being able to meet more people being
able to meet people who i'm not in the
same city with
um and we're definitely tapping into all
of those things um
through the gst or the more structured
global experiences
um i think outside of that it's just
everything that's still
going on as usual so we have our we have
certain classes that focus
on the international experience um we
have a lot of
different people from different
countries in our class people who are
right now
um like robert who are taking classes
from different time zones and that just
um kicks off conversations that did not
happen before when we were in the same
place doing the same thing
um so i think in a way it's encouraged
more conversation
about diversity it's just happening on
its own
you mentioned this really interesting
concept of in a virtual world
you know you're having some different
conversations and even the way you're
connecting might be
different right and so um for those of
you
who have who likely are active in this
right now like how has this
changed the way you network and build
like either community or relationships
any tips for folks
in the audience about how they might
think about developing
um these meaningful relationships given
kind of
the circumstance we're in and today
maybe some of david's interests
the future of work
yeah i can talk a little bit about that
so
i think uh sure things are hard uh
hard work to do virtually after doing a
day
full of classes on zoom zoom fatigue is
real
but whenever you are on a virtual event
um
i think that works slightly better this
is this might be a hot day but this
works slightly better than
in person because i remember seeing
social events
that used to happen in person people of
similar
interests similar identities would end
up like hanging out together yeah you
know
in a big group there would certainly be
small groups that would get
formed and you would see people are like
similar-ish
you know um and with zoom you're put
into random breakout rooms now you are
interacting with
more people who are different than you
than you would you otherwise would uh
and um we have been doing talks
virtually uh for those of you who don't
know
talk is like a gsb tradition where every
week
uh uh two to four two of our classmates
share uh their life's story in a very
vulnerable
uh way like they share a lot of personal
details that
you know they otherwise would not and i
think because stocks are virtual a lot
many more people
are able to actually join join the locks
because there's no commute involved you
can you can join
where wherever you are from and you
don't have to come on the name of the
campus
so uh sure things a lot of things are
not translating
good but some things have definitely
become better
um i can also add my two cents so
overall i think
our our mba twos here have a better
comparative
experience for me i came here and it was
completely
like it was mostly virtual um i think my
sense is that
given the choice most of us prefer to
have
more in person but i do feel like uh
number one this is also much better than
like whatever i was experiencing before
and number two i actually felt that
there was some advantage that
a virtual environment brings so the
first one is that um in the classroom
setting so like to
to my passion about education um there's
one quote i really like about online
education which is
in the in the good old times you only
have a few people in the
in the front row but now in the zoom
setting you can have everyone in the
front row
like you can kind of like put on gallery
view and you know see everyone's face
and
and um even the chat i think we found it
quite lively so far
just being able to like clarify stuff
quickly and all that so it's pretty
interactive uh and i think some of the
professors not all professors have done
a good job but some of them have done a
really good job in terms of
adapting uh to the zoom setting so uh my
first week here we did a class called
managing teams and behavior
uh i think the nba 2 is usually like i
can see the nodding
you know people like it um and and this
year i think it was
surprisingly good even though it was in
a virtual setting
because we were doing like team
activities and reflections and sharing
and all that
you know overzoo and it was actually
done in a very
very effective way so i really enjoyed
that
um and then the other thing i would say
that's good about sort of the virtual
setting
is that um in the past you need someone
to like come to campus before you can
see them
but now in a way you get to access like
opportunities from across the world
so some of the actually mba tools i've
talked to they might be in brazil they
might be in china like robert
or some of the speakers that we can
bring onto campus
i'll sort of bring out tinkerers um i
think now there's just more flexibility
to like talk to anyone
so that's something that i thought was
quite um
quite a pleasant surprise as well uh i
think a couple of weeks ago
there was a talk in stanford with bill
gates and then there's one with eric uin
of zoom
and like every day just you know
something super interesting and
you can sit in front of your computer
and and listen to all these cool people
so
i thought that was pretty exciting
go ahead all okay yeah i was just going
to add on to what david was saying like
i think
even for classes what we've discovered
is because of the virtual environment
like for actually doing the cases a lot
more people are now open to come just
because it's just joining uh
our long a call versus coming to st
coming to the campus and doing that so
uh we've definitely seen even better
speakers come who would otherwise not
have been able to come because of time
commitments
yeah i've definitely been hearing about
like the silver lining of that
um and you actually put a really cool
spin on that david about
how instead of just a few people like
now everybody's technically
that front row i've i've never actually
thought about it that way before
um and here's a question for those of
you who are thinking
is anybody thinking about um going back
to india or china
post graduation all right so given that
you're here
or we're here depending on where in the
world you are right now
um there's a question here about how
have you leveraged either programming or
informal resources to stay connected
with your home markets
and feel prepared to transition back
um i don't know if david is trying to go
back to you
are you do you want to start uh sure i
feel like uh i'm
furthest away from going back and
graduating but i think
overall my experience has been that um
the alumni community number one is
not super big but it's extremely tight
and extremely well accomplished
um and they're also just very happy to
like connect you to
other people that you know you want to
speak to and all that so they're very
helpful
uh and i think for most of us here at
least the group that's here
we are sort of interested in tech and vc
and i think that's where there's just a
ton of gsb alarms
in the space um yeah
so i i haven't i'm still thinking about
it
um i yeah i think but pre-jsp i used to
work in
asia places like china southeast asia
and also used to work in
sf so i'm still trying to figure out
like where do i want to spend more time
longer term
yeah i can add more to that so i'm
definitely looking to go
back um and the caveat is i'm looking to
go back to india but i'm also spending a
bunch of time in london
um for personal reasons so i'm just
talking about like moving outside of the
us more broadly
um and i would say there are two three
different types of things so one is just
the informal network
um so the gsb network i found both at
least in my experiences in london and
india
is extremely tight-knit so there are
already a lot of people in india
who i call up for any opportunity i'm
thinking about even if it was my summer
and not necessarily india so just
a lot of advice that happens um i know
there's a lot of support that happens in
terms of recruiting
and then going forward um there's like
this
the vc network versus the
entrepreneurial network people find
their co-founders their people find
their first investors their people find
um you know lps for their vc fund there
so it's just
it's not just the first thing you do
after graduating but it's sort of a
longer term
um like the people who become your core
circle
um going forward in your career um
coming back more shorter term i think
there's a lot of structured
opportunities to help you do this
um and i want to talk about a few things
especially around
like internships and summers and finding
jobs and two that i want to highlight
are
seed and gmix what these are essentially
summer internship programs
um gmx is sort of a global experience
where for a month there's a lot of
global opportunities that get posted and
if you're interested in trying something
out you can work and people did
um everything from like top-end
hospitality change to working with
governments um like literally like the
top government people in countries in
africa and all over the world um and
then the second one is seed where you
actually get
um if you want to work for a younger
startup or company
um especially in countries like india
where the pay scales might not
match a lot of the financial
considerations that you have stanford
actually supports you to do that
um and i think that's uh super so i did
a state internship i wanted to work with
a young startup
working in agriculture and i got support
from stanford so it makes it very easy
to find like new companies go back
uh without really taking a big financial
hit um
so wonder call out likes are sort of
structured and of course there's a
career management center i want to call
that out so
we have a few dedicated resources
focused on internationals
um and they provide a lot of one-on-one
support so allocate and i was just in a
chat with
um three people from the career
management center who just asked about
what are the people from india club
looking at what are the people from
china club looking at for them
um and then they build those one-on-one
relationships um
and fight like with those companies back
in india
if you're looking to recruit yeah i was
talking to some of the folks in the
career management center
they love when folks are interested kind
of
broadly all over the world just because
i think for them too it
makes it really interesting to be able
to help find new opportunities for our
students
so we're getting close to the top of the
hour so i want to make sure we have time
for this last question
um so thinking back to like a younger
you so for david that might have been
last year
for the rest of you it might have been a
couple years ago or maybe
as you were starting your mba program
if you can give yourself one piece of
advice
what would it be so i'll give you a
moment to think about that
and then whoever is ready can go ahead
and jump on and
share
i can go first and give others
hello oh
perfect uh i think for me what i've
learned in a circle
going after all of my all the first year
is basically
everyone's faced with this battle
between following your head versus
following your heart
and i think the head tells you you
should do so many things whereas the
heart says that you want to do so many
things and i think what i've discovered
is
when you follow your heart you just have
so much more fun
so i think for me uh if there was one
thing which i would want to
kind of know before start starting gsp
is that
this place is so amazing it helps you
set you up for whatever you want to do
it just makes so much sense to follow
your heart over your head
and i wish i knew that before
i'm happy to go next even though i'm
pretty new here
uh one thing i would say is to be
kinder to yourself and i say that
because
like coming here a lot of us are quite
perfectionist right
we we want to get the best grades you
want to meet the most friends you want
to go to the most interesting talks and
all that
and you just tend to overburden yourself
um just you know be too perfectionist
being yourself sometimes um and
you know don't have enough time to relax
chill decompress and all that
uh so for me i think that's that's one
thing i
i would actively want to do just to be
kinder to myself
yeah to that i would say we have this
thing called
stanford duck syndrome where
and which i think is like everywhere not
just stanford
specific especially like for all
b-schools that's true so whenever you're
going to join next year um so what what
it is is that on the
surface you feel like ducks are having
the best time they're just relaxing but
you know under the water they are like
constantly peddling
right and when you come to business
school first few weeks there is just so
much programming so much
socializing to do you feel like you are
the only one struggling because when you
meet someone you ask them hey how are
you doing it's just
oh i'm great it's just amazing so
uh you feel like everybody's life is
just
going super smooth and you are the one
struggling but
it's true for everyone everyone is
struggling uh
and so feel free to talk about it and
just knowing that
i think for me it's more than even
talking to someone about it is just
knowing that everybody's in the same
place
it's not just i was struggling just
gives
makes you feel better about it and you
know that you know you all will get
through it together
um from my side i think david said it
best there's just
so much cool stuff um
foremost real um that
but i'm very grateful to be here and i'm
i'm trying to be very kind to myself
nice and so as you're thinking about
business school and as you embark on
those few years it sounds like
follow your heart so that you have the
most
like you make the most of it you enjoy
your time while you're doing
so be kind to yourself because there's a
lot that
a lot of like burdens you can have on
your shoulders and know that
you're not doing this alone you're with
other people it's
okay to share we want you to share and
there's power and that vulnerability
because we're all in this together so
to all of our panelists thank you
so much for joining us today for all of
the folks at home
thank you for joining us as well we are
going to be ending
this session we have one more day of
programming for diversity and leadership
and we'd love to see you there